last night joe biden promised to reverse
the trump administration's foreign
policy on the question of china
according to biden the u.s will now
follow something called
the international rules of the road what
does that mean exactly well you can
guess what it means more subservience to
the emerging nation of china
most people don't understand how big
this is
or how far back it goes or the
implications for them lee smith
understands he's an author and a
journalist he's written one of the best
pieces of the year on this topic for
tablet magazine
the piece is called the 30 tyrants
you'll have to stop reading midway
through because it's upsetting
but as you read it you'll also know it's
true so we recommend that you do he
joins us tonight to explain
lee thanks so much for coming on and for
the mental energy required to connect
all these dots in the piece and again i
really hope our readers
read it for themselves but in the
meantime when you summarize your
position
yeah i mean basically what i wanted to
explain is i wanted to explain why so
many things look crazy
many things for instance that you cover
on your show all the time for instance
tonight
why people are coming across the why
people are coming across the border
in such profound numbers it all looks
crazy
until you realize there's a reason it's
going on and the reason is
is because the oligarchy that runs this
country now
is not primarily loyal to the united
states
they do not care about the amount of
damage they do to america
they don't care about the amount of
damage they do to americans
that's part of the system their primary
loyalty is to
their relationship to the communist
chinese party
that is the their center of gravity it's
the source of their wealth
privilege and prestige
so keep connecting if you would and
and i and i hope sure that again people
will read this because print is really
the only medium that can fully explain a
thesis
as complex as yours but i think you're
right so what else would connect
to that point that you just made well i
mean the
the big thing is starting i mean one of
the key dates is of course it starts
with henry kissinger's
uh and richard m nixon's uh opening to
china but really a big a big date is
1994 when bill clinton decided
decided to de-link human rights and
trade
regarding china right the ambition you
hear people say all the time oh
uh we were hopeful that china would
adopt more democratic policies
it was nonsense the premier of china at
the time mujiang jimin
this was the man who was catapulted to
power after sending tanks into tiananmen
square
so the american elite knew exactly what
they were getting into
what they looked at they looked at an
enormous cheap
labor pool and they said we're going to
get rich and that's precisely what
happened
we're we are more than a quarter of a
century along
and that's precisely what's happened now
one of the interesting things that
happened during
during the donald trump presidency
because donald trump started calling
these people out
i think that donald trump didn't even
have that clear a sense of how tied in
how extensive this network was one of
the examples i i mentioned is for
instance
whoever would have put apple ceo tim
cook and lebron james in the same family
album
but there they are sure enough because
they both rely
their wealth relies on the two same
things cheap chinese labor and a growing
chinese consumer market
if you look across this is not just it's
not just entertainment
it's not just tech uh it goes into the
corporate worlds it goes into finance
unfortunately it affects our government
throughout one of the most astonishing
revelations
was a was a memo that former dni john
ratcliffe wrote
regarding uh regarding the cia regarding
their intelligence analysis
cia management was apparently bullying
analysts saying
they didn't like their analysis of china
because they were worried about the
policies it might encourage
meaning donald trump's policies who was
hard on china
therefore cia management was protecting
china from solid analysis it's
astonishing but take it one step further
remember who owns uh who owns the cloud
on which all of the cia's information is
collected and that's jeff bezos
who is china's number one distributor in
the united states
in in 10 seconds does it shock you that
the new defense secretary has basically
said
the greatest certainty faces not china
but white supremacists in this country
no not at all if you look at the biden
administration the way it's staffed and
unfortunately if you look at the first
family
you see that there are deep and
extensive ties to the chinese communist
party it doesn't surprise me at all
amazing piece lee i appreciate you
coming on tonight thank you very much
tucker thanks